if you want to find out how you can win
this pennywise keychain then stick
around to the end of this video
the moment we've all been waiting for
since 129 minutes into the first movie
has arrived and basically 12 videos in
one terrible song later
it's chapter 2 happy death day to you it
chapter 2
is here so let's take a look at the
things you missed
the movie opens with a shot from the
first film beverly marsh floating after
being abducted by pennywise which
suggests that this event has a greater
significance than we previously realized
we later find out that because beverly
looked into the deadlights as a kid she
has the ability to see things that the
others cannot which is hinted at in the
last scene
i saw us all of us together back in the
cistern
but we were older our parents ages
i just remember how we felt
how scared we were i don't think i can
ever forget that
we then see an extended version of that
scene where stan the man asks what he
looks like as an adult and if you look
at beverly's reaction she looks sad for
a moment before lying to him
saying that he'll be the same but taller
we all know what happens to stan
nope no put that down we then flash
forward to dairy in 2016 which is the
most modern depiction of the fictional
town that appears in many of stephen
king's works the dairy canal days
festival is going on and three anti-gay
teens harass a couple
adrian mellon and don hagerty the movie
shows how adrian ended up with the i
heart dairy hat which in the book is the
item that sets adrian's attacker over
the edge no pun intended the scene is
also inspired by a real crime that
occurred in the 80s while the book was
being written
the way the three attackers act is very
similar to how henry bowers and his gang
of bullies behave in the first film and
that may be a clue about how the
phenomenon of violence that mike hanlon
calls the dairy disease is now impacting
a new generation of teens melon is
thrown off the bridge and pennywise
secretly makes his appearance in the
background for a brief moment while
melon pops up for air
in the next scene we see mike hanlon
hearing the news of the crime over
police scanners and i noticed a
photograph of his uncle from the first
movie
the uncle takes over the role his father
played in the novel so i think it's
reasonable to assume that he probably
passed away in a similar manner during
the 27 year gap which may be the reason
mike decides to stay in derry and
investigate more about why
bad things happen so often in this town
the next losers club member we meet is
bill who's on set filming a movie
adaptation of attic room
in the novel the black rapids is the
name of the book that gets made into a
movie and attic room is actually bill's
first original screenplay the change may
have been made because each one of
bill's stories represents one of his
experiences in derry and attic room
would have been inspired by the events
at 29 meeble street which are focused on
much more in the first movie
they're shooting attic room on the
warner brothers lot and conversely you
can go to the warner brothers lot right
now and you'll see this
it's almost as if they want people to go
see this movie the director is a real
life director peter bogdanovich likely
because the director of it andy
muschietti is a fan
the next adult loser we meet is eddie
you probably noticed that his wife myra
looks exactly like his mom from the
first movie but if you haven't read the
book you might not get the joke eddie
realizes the woman he married is
basically exactly like his mother when
he finds an old photo of his mom
he looks from mother tamara and then
back again to mother they could have
been sisters the resemblance was that
close
the movie takes it a step further by
literally using the same actress for
both characters
in the new movie eddie is a risk
assessment specialist for an insurance
company but the fact that he gets in a
car accident when he receives the call
from mike allen is a slight nod to his
limo driver career in the book
after richie we meet ben who's now an
architect he's in a meeting with his
associates where he makes an argument
for an open floor plan telling them if
you throw up walls it feels like a
prison the point is to bring people
together
whether he remembers it or not the
reason he feels this way is because he's
felt the power of unity before when he
and his friends came together to defeat
pennywise this is what it wants
it wants to divide us we were all
together
when we heard it that's why we're still
alive
ben also compares the office building to
a clubhouse a hint that we would finally
see the clubhouse in the barrens that
was left out of both adaptations so far
when we see the exterior shot of ben's
home office there's a turtle statue a
reference to the entity known as the
turtle in the book which is essentially
the rival of its who gives the losers
club small helping hands along the way
the turtle is referenced a few times in
the first film and would be referenced
again later in chapter 2 when a turtle
can be spotted on the desk
during ben's classroom scene the turtle
like it is a cosmic entity and on cue
the camera tilts up to the stars
perhaps a hint that the interdimensional
origins of its will further be explained
in this film
the shot transitions into stan's living
room where mr yuris is doing a bird
puzzle little nod to stanley's hobby in
the book
bird watching stan takes his life when
hearing about its return
and the blood dripping off his hand
transitions to a leak dripping onto
beverly which is exactly what happened
to bill's drawing of beverly in the
first one which by the way
leaks through three holes in the ceiling
and later in chapter two the three balls
of light that represent the deadlights
come down into the chamber from above
at the end of the sequence we see what
happened to henry bowers and although we
don't see how he survived the fall down
the well we do see his arrest for the
murder of his father and the guy who
slaps the cuffs on him has a name tag
reading
borton chief borton plays a pretty big
role in the book namely interrogating
the father of the corcoran brothers
after the death of one and the
disappearance of the other
adults henry is driven into a mad fit of
laughter after seeing a red balloon
floating outside the asylum that he now
resides in and is taken to his room
where another connection to king's novel
can be spotted in the background
near henry's bed in the room there are
several pictures of the moon pinned up
to the wall
and i'm like 99 sure that one of them
was the moon from termina in majora's
mask but the reason for these moons is
that in the novel it manipulates henry
by giving him orders from what henry
perceives to be a voice coming from the
moon
henry henry
so zombie patrick breaks henry out of
juniper hills and later that night
the adult versions of our cast are
reconvening it's me
the losers club has officially begun
when eddie's walking in he's in the
middle of explaining something to the
waitress he says if i eat a cashew i
could
realistically die the pause before he
says those last two words foreshadows
the fact that eddie is the next
character to kick the bucket
the group gets to talking about bill's
career as a writer and we find out that
attic room wasn't his first movie
adaptation
a situation that mirrors the scenario of
adaptations of its in real life the
movie is telling us that this may not be
the first time that someone has decided
to tackle king's 1986 novel but things
are gonna go differently this time
around
especially with everyone bill meets
telling him that they love his writing
but he needs to work on his endings
when they eventually get around to
talking about it the cycle of the
monster is described as an echo that
comes back every 27 years i find this
word choice interesting because one of
the new forms that the creature takes is
a bat and bats of course rely on echo
communication to get around
the idea of bats being one of the forms
is new for this version although there
is a vampire form that ben sees briefly
in the novel
mike tries to explain the horrors that
have gone down this past summer to the
others and briefly mentions the name
lisa albrats like chief borton this is
another subtle reference to the expanded
events of the book where it's takes out
this young girl on the anniversary of
georgie's death to try to send a message
to mike
it manipulates the fortune cookies first
to give the clue about stanley's death
and then to use their own fears against
them we see that the bat is one of these
richie gets the crawling eyeball with
tentacles an homage to his fear of a
horror movie called the crawling eye
mike's cookie hatches into a bird a
connection to the giant bird that
attacked him in the book and a bird that
attacked him in his crib as an infant
beverly spurts out blood a reminder of
her bathroom sink that spouts blood that
only the kids can see
then there's this mutated insect with a
baby's head this is a combination of
eddie's problem in the book where he
can't get rid of the crickets in his
basement and the problem of infertility
all seven members of the losers club are
unable to conceive a baby as adults
any little crumb snatches for you richie
none that i know of
while everyone is still undecided on if
they want to stay and fight it makes the
next move luring a young girl from the
bleachers of a little league game using
a lightning bug a form that again
could be connected to the deadlights the
girl's name victoria
does not line up with one of the victims
in the book but it may be a little
homage to the original it's the 1990 tv
miniseries
who are you the encounter is very
similar to the georgie scene in chapter
one and that pennywise lures her in with
something that she wants in this case
removing the scar from her face
he says that he's gonna do it on a count
of three but the count ends after
reaching two much like how it
ends after chapter two that evening mike
takes bill to the library and in the
background there's a circus poster with
pennywise on it though it's not clear to
me yet if this is a part of it
influencing the town or part of mike's
research in a dairy
i did spot a book that mike had been
looking into on his desk a history of
old dairy by branson buttinger
this is the same book that ben checks
out in the library in the first one
and the author is a character from the
novel it buttinger who had died in 1950
was a historian who mike lines up from a
former dairy librarian who tries
persuading mike not to look into derry's
past
after publishing the book a history of
old dairy which exposed the violent
pattern of the town's past buttinger was
found dead by his own hand
but like all of the tragedies in this
town something prevents the story from
picking up significant news coverage
another book that i noticed in my study
was called the pillar in the sky
it may be a reference to the dark tower
a series of stephen king books that
expand on the mythology of deities such
as the turtle
mike has bill perform the smokehole
ceremony in the book the seven of them
do this as kids but only richie and mike
have the vision about the arrival of it
but in the movie bill is able to see the
abstract vision of the three beacons of
light which match what beverly saw in
the first movie
and it which shape-shifts into a couple
of different forms such as mike's giant
bird and the spider creature that they
see at the end
after bill seeing this vision and
beverly telling of the nightmare she had
of their deaths the group decides to
stay and fight back against it and mike
takes them back to the barons where they
come across their old clubhouse
in the flashback they wear surgical
capsule in the clubhouse to prevent
spiders from getting in their hair
to which richie asks if they're really
going to be afraid of spiders
in the end overcoming their fear of the
spider form of pennywise is how they
ultimately defeat it
mike gives them the mission to find the
artifacts of their past throughout dairy
during which there are more flashbacks
like beverly's abusive father covering
her with her late mother's perfume the
scene reminds me a lot of this one line
from the book in which beverly describes
her dad's increasing willingness to
raise his hands against her
it was as if there was a smell they made
between them a smell that wasn't there
when she was in the apartment alone
one that had never been there when they
were in it together not until this
summer and when mom was gone it got
worse
if there was a smell some smell then he
knew it too because bev saw less and
less of him as the hot weather wore on
beverly goes back to her old apartment
where mrs kirsch now lives she notices
something is off when she spots the
holes on mrs kirch's chest a lasting
injury from where ben stabbed the
monster with the fire poker 27 years ago
rolls
the next thing beverly notices is a
photo of mrs kirsch and her fodder
my father joined the circus and aside
from the familiar facial features of
this man there's also a familiar looking
trailer in the background
the next flashback would come from
richie who revisits the old movie
theater arcade where an interesting
detail can be found
[Music]
the old movie theater has been closed
down with the marquee now simply reading
thanks for the memories
which is kind of a shame because they
could have put up posters for warner
brothers movies from 2016 like lights
out and the conjuring too
but instead there's just an old left
behind poster for you've got mail which
tells us that the theater probably
closed in 1998.
nine years after the initial battle with
pennywise also this is the second meg
ryan reference so far
the first being adrian millen telling
the bullies that meg ryan wants her wig
back in the opening
ritchie flashes back to a scene where he
flees from henry bowers and takes a safe
haven in city center where he is
attacked by the paul bunyan statue who
has bats flying out of his mouth which
explains the aforementioned fortune
cookie with the bats
then in the present richie reads a flyer
for his own funeral which is either a
callback to the missing poster from the
first movie or the poster for richie
closure's all-dead rock show from the
book
or both could be both meanwhile bill
goes into a shop called secondhand rose
where he sees his old bike silver the
shopkeep is none other than stephen king
himself which provides an interesting
conversation given that bill as a
character is already kind of an
extension of stephen king it's almost as
if king is having a conversation with an
older version of himself
something that actually happens during
the climax of the movie during the
ritual of chud
king also has a copy of the black rapids
the fictional bill denbro book that i
mentioned earlier bill tells the
shopkeep that his old bike was
fast enough to beat the devil and the
line is a direct reference to the
chapter title
bill den bro beats the devil which is
brought back as the tagline of the
book's epilogue
next bill revisits his old house where a
new family now lives the son is a kid
who rides a skateboard the bottom of his
board displays the carpet pattern seen
outside of room 237 in the shining the
skateboard kid does appear in the novel
briefly bill tells him to be careful to
which he replies you can't be careful on
a skateboard a line that continues to
come up in bill's mind throughout the
book
in the movie bill tells him to be
careful and the kid just looks back
maybe i'm looking into it too much but
maybe this is muscularity telling us
that things are going to go differently
from here on out
and after seeing this thing it's hard to
say i can blame him
ben searches for his artifact back at
the high school
he flashes back to a scene that took
place while the kids were back in school
after this fight but before defeating it
it's interesting how both movies added a
scene of it taking the form of beverly
in order to try to trick ben
as far as i can remember there's nothing
like that in the novel in this version
however
before ben kisses her she turns into a
monster with a flaming head i believe
this is it taunting him about the poem
he had written her turning the line
your hair is winter fire into something
literal also worth noting
this could be a reference to another
creepy clown the sweet tooth from the
twisted metal
franchise however i don't think it was
intentional because the scenes where ben
as a kid took place in 1989 and twisted
metal wouldn't come out until 1995.
also ben saves himself by locking
himself in a locker a scene that is very
similar to creepy clown's school
lockdown epidemic i might need to have
my lawyers take a look into this one
and perhaps even more suspicious than
that is in the next sequence where eddie
stops in to pick up his prescription at
center street drug
and they somehow have me in the
background browsing the aisles
oh wait that's actually a cameo from the
director andy muschietti which completes
the trifecta of cameos bogdanovic king
and muschietti if you were wondering if
the woman behind the counter is greta
keen the same girl who writes loser on
eddie's cast
she's still wearing the same necklace
with the letter g eddie's flashback
takes him to a scene where he's lured
to the basement of the pharmacy when he
hears his mother's voice crying for help
he looks behind the curtain to discover
his mother tied up to a chair with a
leper coming for her
though this is only an illusion created
by its he's unable to save her but this
is a visual setup for when eddie
overcomes his fear of the horrors that
are beyond the curtain later on as an
adult when he punctures through the
shower curtain to kill his attacker
henry bowers
when i covered the first movie one thing
i pointed out was how tim curry is
pennywise from the mini-series
adaptation of it makes a small cameo in
the clown room
chapter 2 continues that tradition when
bill makes his way through the haunted
house in an attempt to rescue the
skateboard kid these swinging clown
pendulums share the yellow suit purple
vest parted tufts of red hair and red
rubber nose that can be found on curry's
pennywise whereas none of these features
can be found on the new design for bill
skarsgard's pennywise when he gets into
the hall of mirrors pennywise appears
for less than a second in the background
during one of the strobes of light
after being unable to save the
skateboard kid bill loses it and goes
alone to the house where they had
encountered it so many years before
29 niebold street just like when bill
foolishly ran off to face the threat
alone as a child his friends give chase
to come aid him
they go inside where they come up
against a bit of a bridge between
something that happens in the book
and the second coming of something that
happens in the first movie in the first
film pennywise comes out of this fridge
to attack them
time to float and in the book they're
having a discussion in the library and
it uses the form of stan's head inside
of the mini-fridge to taunt and frighten
[Music]
them
sorry i'm late well let's see who's here
so when the amazing spider stand comes
out of the fridge it does a good job of
bringing those two worlds together
the idea of someone's head turning into
a spider and the line that richie says
when he sees it is also a reference to
jon carpenter's the thing
you gotta be [ __ ] kidding
we also see the h on ben's abdomen that
henry carved in the first movie reappear
this time spelling out the words home at
last
after another run-in with the monstrous
version of mrs kirsch who apparently
didn't get the memo about its
catchphrase
no not that one you lied
and i died no the other one time to
float
yeah that one they end up finding a
manhole in the cistern that leads them
deeper into the sewers and this is where
they all must perform the smokehole
ritual together in a scene that's filled
with even more
secrets
the matches that mike uses to start the
fire that begins the smokehole ritual
are from jade of the orient the chinese
restaurant that they meet at for the
reunion the ritual of chur begins and
this isn't a thing you missed but i just
feel the need to point out that i
[ __ ] called it when i uploaded this
video on may 25th
roll it i just think that they have to
make a cooler looking arachnid than the
one from 1990. maybe instead of a giant
spider it's more of a half clown half
spider alien hybrid
now i know what you're thinking i should
just mic drop and walk away but the mic
is actually up there and i still have a
few more things you missed and i'm
actually borrowing this mic at the
moment and i don't really want to risk
breaking it
the point is you owe me a like on this
video or something but anyway each of
the losers is thrown
into their own personal scenarios where
they must overcome pennywise for beverly
she's thrown into the bathroom stall
where she was bullied as a young girl or
at least
some twisted version of it the word
smokehole can briefly be seen written on
the wall and the blood that nearly
drowns her is an extreme version of the
blood that came out of her father's
bathroom sink
in the first movie it's a symbol for her
struggles with reaching the age of
puberty but in this film it's more of a
reminder of the abuse that she endured
as a child
and this is solidified by the fact that
the characters that poke their heads
into the bathroom stall are the three
predatory characters that objectified
her her father
the pharmacist and henry bowers who
screams here's johnny as he pokes his
head around the door
here's johnny i did a whole video on the
connection between the shining and it
which you can watch right here or find
the link in the description at the end
of this video eddie and richie encounter
the set of three doors that terrified
them in the first movie and behind the
first one there's a pair of legs
unattached to a body if you remember in
chapter one bill and richie open the
door and see the severed upper body of
their missing classmate betty ripson
so i think that this kind of shows that
they're in an inverse of that world
i also find it kind of funny that they
actually didn't get the same actress
back for the sequel
so the new actress is credited as betty
ripson's legs after everyone makes it
out of their personal battles with it
eddie finds his bravery and attacks the
monster which retaliates and seriously
maims eddie leaving a smudge of clown
makeup on his cheek
if you look closely you can see the word
it though i probably don't have the
footage for this so you have to go back
and see the movie
[Music]
when the losers get an advantage over
it's the creature cycles among many of
the forms and you can tell that it's
losing its touch when it briefly takes
the form of the woman in the painting
which is stan's fear and he hasn't been
around since like 15 minutes into the
movie
to be fair though that thing is pretty
freaky regardless of if you're stan or
not
after losing eddie the others are able
to come together and finally put an
end to the thing that has caused the
horrors around a dairy for all of these
years
and they escape from the knee bolt house
just before it collapses this is a
scaled down version of the way that the
book ends where an epic flood destroys
dairy and symbolically purges all of the
evil that had taken place there so this
was one thing that i was a little
disappointed with for this movie the
storm scene would have been wild but as
i mentioned way back at the beginning of
this video it was well established that
the movie was going to do something
different because bill denbrough who
kind of represents stephen king
is criticized for his story endings by
his wife peter bogdanovich and
basically everyone he meets along the
way so his next book that we see him
writing in the epilogue has a more
positive ending
and its chapter 2 follows suit the town
is not destroyed the evil is
conclusively vanquished and the
remaining members of the losers club
don't lose their memories again when
they leave derry bill denbroe does once
again beat the devil but this time it's
a personal demon that he's overcoming
the ancient evil that for so long
haunted derry was now gone
but you still have a chance to have your
very own evil entity in the form of this
keychain
that's right i'm giving this thing away
and here's how you can be entered to win
it first follow cz's world on instagram
then find this post and leave a like the
winner will be selected at random
full contest rules can be found in the
video description i think i'm going to
be vlogging more
related events on the instagram from now
on so maybe you can even stick around
and not just unfollow me after the
giveaway but that's your call
so that's it pun intended of course
there may be a few things that i miss
so let me know what you might have
noticed in the comments and i'll
probably do a follow-up episode once the
movie comes out on blu-ray so i can
really dig deep for any details that
went under the radar in this video
so make sure you are subscribed to cz's
world for new horrors every week ring
that death bell for
notifications and i'll see you in the
next one assuming
we both survive